hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com
so for those who are watching my video
for the first time let me quickly
introduce myself i've been working as a
professional trader for the past six
years in
hong kong and right now guys i'm making
youtube videos
because i want to pass the knowledge i
want to show you all the different tools
and techniques
that i like to use at work to make money
on the markets
and most importantly and those who are
watching my video for some time they
know this is true
i want to explain you guys how to do it
yourself so i'm expanding my
analysis step by step so that you can
follow what i'm doing
so in today's video i want to make a
massive update guys on amc
that is reaching the targets one by one
let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so a few things i want to
show you in this video so maybe
the first thing let me remind you my two
scenarios
or maybe let me take a step back you
know i like to do this sometimes so i'm
on the forward time frame
and i want to explain to you guys you
know the reason why i was so bullish
here so that you can use
this methods on any other stock i know
that amc has
very specific reasons for this uh press
action to develop this way
but the mechanisms that are behind it
are still the same that you can find
in any bullish price action development
and by the way i want to stress
something out guys
look at this price action here so i'm
gonna follow us time frame
i mean you know if you just forget about
the scale
that of course is explosive here
but this price action to me just looks
normal
you know and i'm gonna come to the point
i want to bring you guys
is that this was not normal right look
you see this was not normal this
is a squeeze this is a massive buyback
of short positions
by short investors like hedge funds all
right
and when this happens you have those
moves so this was the move we had in jen
we had 400 percent guys
in a matter of eight hours all right
this is a squeeze
here we're not having a squeeze guys
we're having a stock that is going
higher
because it deserves to go higher for
i would say healthy reasons i'm not
having here an
unhealthy price action development
nothing that
for now is scaring me i'm having here a
very
bullish stock that is just going higher
in a very bullish way that's true
but not in a healthy way so
i think that this is sustainable if we
go to much higher levels
so i give you a target of 135 by next
week
let's see guys let's see what is uh
playing out you know
once again i have another scenario that
is a bit less
bullish but that goes to the same level
maybe we correct here maybe here
but ultimately we're gonna go here guys
you know i'm very convinced of this and
the reason why i'm convinced of this is
because
here what i'm seeing is clean and when i
have that clean
price action development so guys of
course
uh i'm not 100 sure but usually yes this
is
the kind of development that we're gonna
keep having
and for now this is not complete to me
so yeah that's
what i wanted to tell you in this video
the first thing
and i also wanted to show you something
else guys
you know we're talking here about 380
percent you know
in in uh in in eight hours so we are
very
very far from it yet because we're not
having a squeeze
yet guys i'm really waiting to see the
short interest data
coming from the finra reports that it's
very important because even if there are
some
naked shots and i know they are in this
market the regular shots are still
a very good indication of what hedge
funds are doing because most hedge funds
are actually declaring their positions
properly
so for now we're not having this squeeze
happening i'm going to bring you to this
data
very soon guys but here i just want to
show you something that you know
you might be interested to see is that
if this scenario plays out
then we have this scenario coming all
right so don't focus about this level
it's a random level i would
i cannot give you a precise target that
far i'm gonna keep
updating you guys all the way up and for
now as you can see
my targets have been reached and each
time we had
some reactions around the levels i was
telling you
i also told you the way we're gonna go
there and this is what is happening
why am i right here because we're having
a healthy bullish development if it was
a squeeze
no one can know where we're gonna go
this is going beyond idiot wave theory
but idiot wave theory can still
help you to know where we are in terms
of the development of the waves and
they're still
gonna happen guys for the same reasons
they always do
is because when something makes a lot of
noise and amc
is making a lot of noise right now some
people that were not in this trade are
gonna come to this trade
usually a bit late and this is what we
call the fifth wave
all right so fifth wave is actually
created
by some new investors that usually
arrive a bit late because if they buy
here and they don't sell here
there are those who actually gonna pay
all the ones that vote here
and i know that this is you guys so
for now we have time we don't have all
the fifth waves complete we
having them one by one and each time you
have the fifth wave complete you have a
massive
correction or consolidation for now
we're concentrating here
but i think we still have a few fifth
wave to come
in larger degree wave countings all
right
because you know when the noise spreads
sometimes it takes time and at the time
it's going to spread
far enough so that all the fifth waves
are going to be complete
and we might see the squeeze happening
especially guys if hedge funds
can't resist and they would not resist
to sell
shares at those very you know high
levels and i'm gonna follow this very
closely i'm gonna date you guys so let
let me bring you to my
dashboard and yes i'm gonna keep
updating you with
what i'm seeing here and guys in my last
video i updated you guys with the 70
strike calls happening but look
what i found i mean it's easy to find i
just didn't check
but we're having 145 strike calls
listed right now uh and we already have
like a lot of shares like three million
equivalent shares
and what is very funny guys to watch
three 2.7 million equivalent shares and
what is very
interesting not funny it's just
interesting as is that it's coming from
the june maturity guys in
11 days uh no sorry 18th of junes in
13 days two weeks that's possible guys
my target is next week
so maybe in two weeks so i mean i don't
think we're gonna go to 145 but
maybe we would but 135 is definitely
a reasonable level i mean not reasonable
but achievable
level and here guys we having this
bullish momentum that is creating this
you know upset gamma
again that is gonna you know make the
market makers
buy shares right now we're having 4.1
billion usd synthetic short exposure
on the amc option market once again guys
very quickly
this information you can't find it
anywhere what i'm doing here is what i
do at work
i compute the delta myself i use this
formula guys you know
it's black shorts formula very basic
stuff uh and i do it for every maturity
i take the option open interest from
yahoo finance the volatility from yahoo
finance
and i follow this volatility guys you
know because it's an indicator of what
market makers think
of the price action and you can use the
delta as an estimation of the
probability we go
at a given strike so for example the
probability we go to the
145 strike in july is
50 guys this is what the market makers
are pricing 50
this is incredible guys you know
but this is what market makers are full
price
to actually compute this call option
prices so this is the reason why now i'm
going to bring you to some
call options strategies you don't want
to buy those naked calls all right
that too expensive guys you don't want
to buy it it's not
a good trade of course it could be a
winning trade but you have
better trades you can make let me show
you so here
you can start so basically i took this
options from yahoo finance
so july maturity amc training at 47.9
i just copy paste this in my spreadsheet
and i compute my strategies and what i
want to show you guys so okay okay you
can buy the
100 for example 100 call
this is going to cost you 1 000 uh us
dollars and if amc goes to 135
140 you make 3 500 us dollars
all right that's good that's good but
look what you can do you can buy the 100
strike and sell the 135 strike because
i don't think we're going to go higher
than this i think that this is for me
the ceiling
and let's say you do this
then guys it costs you only 250 usd
so five times less and how much money
you make if amc goes there
the same money so you just sacrifice the
upside performance above the 135 level
but this is why it's good to combine
those option strategies with technical
analysis
because you know technical analysis will
tell you where you're going to have some
reactions or you just buy you know the
100 call
and you put some sending orders if you
have shares
this is also what you can do if you have
100 shares
you can also do like this and then when
we come to 135
here you can sell two for example so
you're just
capping your upside performance here the
same way
what i mean is that you have different
ways to build your strategies but
keep in mind that this volatility here
let me just show you guys this
volatility here
is very expensive guys all right and
you just need to keep in mind then
you see we are talking about vols of 350
all right 350 so
in terms of daily moves you just divide
this by 16
and it gives you the daily move bam so
we're talking about
22 of daily moves which is fair all
right which is fair
but guys keep in mind that buying those
call options
is not the best strategy you can make
another strategy is that you make a
butterfly
butterfly is very cheap guys you need to
select your strikes
in a symmetric way so here i have this
85 you start wherever you want and plus
30 all right
so 115 plus 30 145
and then you do a one by two by one this
the sum
of all your options so uh one minus two
plus one
must be zero if this is symmetrical and
then you have a butterfly
and look the price of a butterfly guys
here i'm updating the price same with my
formula
just a vlookup and four hundred us
dollars
you can make up to 000 us dollars but
it's very hard
to actually you know find the level it's
gonna end
here so a butterfly is cheaper but it's
harder to make you know the same profits
but you can just double your butterfly
you know and then you can make up to 6
000 so you just
you know depending on the risk profile
you want to have you can make some
beautiful strategies but just keep in
mind guys
that buying those cool options without
selling anything is very expensive as
at this very very high volatility but of
course if we go
higher they're gonna keep increasing so
it's gonna be a good trade
but you need to time it very properly
which is difficult even when you
use technical analysis that is telling
you for example that this week we're
going to go there
you can't be sure you can't be sure so
you buy a cold spread once again this
is what i would do i would buy 135
code spreads for example 2x2 up
up so for 500 us dollars i can make up
to 6 000
and this is once again for the july
maturity so
another thing i wanted to show you is
yeah i'm gonna follow this
very closely guys i can't wait for the
28th
of may here to be released
28 because for now i don't have this
data guys but i really want to know
what is the short interest sorry 28th of
may
i really want to know what is the short
interest here guys
uh for now this data is not available
but when it's going to be
if i see here that the short interest is
growing
guys this means that we're going to
start having this unhealthy
you can call it this way moves that are
going to
squeeze hard all right imagine a 380
move from here brings us actually to my
target
so if we go to my target in eight hours
then i would tell you this is a squeeze
but if we go there
you know the same way we did here which
is you know just
slowly growing this is you know people
buying buying buying
and actually when you look at the
volumes that are training it's not only
people
it's hedge funds and institutional
clients that are buying as well
you you know those volumes it's not only
apes buying
many people are getting into the amc
trade many many investors big investors
there is a lot of money at stake here
a lot of professional investors
understood that
the right side is on the buy side and
they're getting in the straight as well
and they're helping pushing the price
action
higher and once again guys here i think
we still have
some room so i might be wrong if i am
i would explain what i you know missed
what happened but
for now i am 100 right on my targets of
amc
and let's see i hope i'm gonna keep
being right here i hope
for you guys and i hope for all the apes
community
so that's it for me i hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to four see you guys